c'est non
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
[Musique]
obama
bouamama bavarois
d'abord il ya la fête des mères ensuite
il ya la fête des pères et la fête des
enfants
pourquoi ne célébrons nous pas la fête
des enfants pourquoi ces chers petits
êtres chers de nos chers sans de noces
en greffons de l'eau sperme ne serait-il
pas louer eux aussi une fois l'an
c'est la tendre pensée qui me montait au
coeur l'autre soir tandis que j'ouvrais
machinalement le tiroir aux trésors où
la mère de mes enfants et moi-même
abritons jalousement les charmants
cadeaux qu'année après année les petits
anges confectionne de leurs mains
potelées sous la tendre férule de la
maîtresse d'école en hommage à leurs
chères mamans et à leurs chers papas il
y avait là pêle-mêle sous mes yeux
attendris si collier de nouilles
trois bracelets de macaronis 8 vide
poches en pot de yaourt harmonieusement
enrobé de feutrine mauvais joue
cinq boîtes à bijoux le petit 45 % de
matière grasse et trois magnifiques pied
de lampe de chez qui ravit consigne est
certes mais quand on aime on ne compte
pas
pourquoi ne célébrons nous pas la fête
des enfants pourquoi nous et pas eux
pourquoi au lieu de leur offrir
n'importe quoi n'importe quand les papas
et les mamans de france à leur tour ne
permet-il pas de leurs personnes et
n'exécuteraient t'il pas de leurs
propres mains quelques présent modestes
et sans prétention bien sûr mais qui
s'avérerait tellement plus précieux au
coeur de nos tendres petit que ses
poupées toutes faites ou ses trains
électriques sophistiqué et glacé que
notre négligence et notre égoïsme nous
pousse alors jeté dans les bras après un
baiser furtif sous prétexte que nous
n'avons pas le courage de trouver le
temps de nous pencher plus tendrement
sur leurs fronts gracile au dessus de
leurs grands yeux brillants ou s'il bat
en éperdue d'amour filial inassouvi aux
quatre vents de la vie qui va ajuster
trépidante au rythme infernal de nos
exigences ambitions carriéristes que
c'est promis c'est promis je vais vous
en donner moi mes chéris des jolis
cadeaux faits à la main il n'y a pas de
raison je vais vous en fabriquer et moi
des schtroumpfs pas cher avec deux
boulettes de villepin et quatre
allumettes je vais vous ont structuré et
des vaisseaux spatiaux en cageots de
patates avec des punaises retourner pour
siège éjectable
et du papier cul pour la combinaison
anti tchernobyl je m'en vais vous en
bidouiller mois des vélos cross sens
elle vraiment hâte qu avec des
couvercles de bidons de dioxine pour
faire les roues et cette connerie tu
shootes boeuf de la tante josiane en
guise de guidon je vais vous en refiler
émois de l'amour en kit réchappé des
poubelles
tiens je suis pas un chien en prime je
composerai moi même le poème
et je vous le dirai moi même au dessert
avec une révérence au début une
révérence à la fin
je doute de pouvoir atteindre dans le
lyrisme les sommets extatique ou votre
mère et moi même film mais emporté l
écoute de la bouleversante déclamation
octosyllabes hic de la dernière fête des
mères dont le texte délicatement
colorier enveloppe encore le joli
cache-pot william saurin de la dernière
fête des pères
c'était très beau je vous le dis tiens
la merveille ma vie est un enchantement
quand je m'endors quand jamais veille ou
quand je joue à tout moment une fée
douce me surveille l e mon tour de soins
charmant cette merveille c'est un moment
authentique
je dois dire que cette oeuvre ne traduit
pas fidèlement la réalité
quand ma fille s'endort c'est moi qui la
couche quand elle s'éveille celle
employée de maison qui l'a lève parce
que le soir ma femme joue au bridge et
le matin elle dort mais c'est beau comme
texte
ça vous prend là là
je me rappelle encore que ma cadette me
l'avez lu en aparté la veille de du
grand jour mais lisez pas tout à fait
comme moi c'est la merveille ma vie est
un enchantement quand je m'endors quand
je m'éveille quand je joue à tout moment
une fédou ce me surveiller le manteau de
soie charmant cette merveille scemama
mental un
jeu mettait alors permis de lui faire
une observation du match c'est très beau
ma chérie c'est très très beau mais mais
vois-tu ça n'est pas très très
personnelle ce texte à 8 ans tu devrais
être capable d'un écrivain toi même mais
papa je suis pas aussi forte en poésie
que la maîtresse
dans quoi on peut les y je suis pas
aussi forte que la maîtresse mais si ma
chérie mais tu sais c'est pas difficile
pour faire une belle peau les i tu
prends de rim par exemple maman et
perrine tu vois en est in et puis tu
colles n'importe quoi devant et puis tu
as une très jolie poésie je sais pas moi
tiens la merveille qui gardent l'outil
surtout de toute façon car note-t-il et
original il est génial c'est le client
qui garde le titre mais tu fais mieux
regarde la merveille je m'appelle
perrine j'aime ma maman mais elle est
dans la marine c'est emmerdant
c'est même pas vrai quoi c'est même pas
vrai qu'ils allaient dans la marine pour
l écoute là tu chipote attend c'est pas
grave je leur fais pouf pouf la
merveille je m'appelle perrine j'aime ma
maman elle est pendant la marine c'est
emmerdant c'est même pas vrai c'est pas
emmerdant qui allait pas dans la marine
pouf pouf la merveille je m'appelle
perrine j'aime ma maman elle est pas
dans la marine en ce moment
comme ça tu comprends si elle change
d'avis si elle s'engage dans la marine
on n'aura qu'à changer la fin
ouais super c'est le piéger en mon papa
c'est le plus fort
je perds mon temps dans le showbiz
j'aurais dû être puéricultrice
quant à ces féroces soldats je le disais
pas pour capter mais ils font rien qu'à
mûrir dans nos campagnes
[Musique]
c'est non non